[Music]
congratulations am i correct you are a
just a few weeks away from being a dad's
yes first-time dad yeah are you ready do
you have you prepared I mean yeah we've
prepared I think almost too much we have
so overloaded with information and
classes and videos what videos are you
watching well funny you should ask
it's we there's a lot of grainy VHS
copies of overweight ladies from the 90s
giving birth floating around out there
if you're interested you know is there
is when when my wife was probably the
first time we I have two kids but the
first time we were told you should watch
these tape yes of women giving birth
yeah it's exactly what you would think
it is if you know anything about you
know physiology and denim from the 90s
because there's a lot of that it was
very a it really kind of hearkened in a
Pavlovian way to pornos for me from a
long time ago I don't not doing what
kind of pornos were you watching it's
there but they have well they have the
music and the grainy quality and similar
production but similar production value
yeah yeah I'm not the climax to it is
way different
it is that handheld there's a lot of
yeah moments but it's all building up to
quite a different moment yes but moaning
and and all that that stuff so yeah it
was and we watched one that was like
about giving birth in water water it was
a very like pro water almost propaganda
it was some people are very into the
idea of giving birth to a baby while
submerged in water that's very pop and
this was like these Russian like
babushkas in giving birth in the Black
Sea and it was like very pro water and
almost condemned you if you didn't do
and there was a song at the end that was
like you know like birth your baby in
the water and it was like God will love
your daughter but only if you birth it
in the water it was like something like
it's a beautiful song well I'm
paraphrasing I think it was haunting and
you know meanwhile there's a woman
underwater and the babies and you know
and I felt like maybe I I felt like God
will frown upon those that don't go to
the Black Sea
yeah to do this you don't have to go to
the Black Sea and also you don't have to
watch more than one of those okay yeah
it sounds like you're watching hundreds
of hours of these videos yeah no after
after this tonight I had another sack to
get through but I think I'll postpone oh
yeah is that is that are you ready with
everything else your your all your set
your you got the crib you got yeah yeah
I'm baby-proof the house yeah I've put
together I put together the crib I'm
always afraid because I've always have
screws left over when I'm done putting
something together and I think it's very
nice that they give you extras but I
don't think they give you extras I think
that those screws should be in the crib
also it's different when you're putting
together a stereo if there's a screw or
two left over okay whatever this is the
thing that hold your baby yeah for the
first two years of its life yeah yeah
that is gonna be the only thing that
touches my baby putting it in the crib
and and walking away
she can play with the screws you know
maybe that's what it's for you're a
terrible father I feel like I sometimes
I feel like I'm really not like
sometimes I'll just be eating a sandwich
in like a lot will things will fall out
of the sandwich like avocado and I think
like this is not how a father eats a
sandwich
I'm not ready you know I know it it's
how a father eats a sandwich yeah that's
good don't worry about it ahead of those
mom I'm just eating like things are
falling I think no you I have to be more
dignified auteurs gonna she's gonna be a
hooligan
if I eat sandwiches like this no no they
don't care so there's no code there's no
proper distinguish way you're throwing
up and pooping on you and so there's no
I mean they're a mess over to you so
you're allowed to pretty much do
whatever you want okay there's a couple
of years so I have time yeah you have
time okay get the crib properly built I
will